hey guys welcome to the evident Galen
podcast episode number 28 paying
attention version 3.0 3.0 coz is the
third down we've started this podcast
yes you know what the first two times
were just practice at the third time
it's gonna be so good it's gonna be so
good so good all the transitions will be
staged well no exactly we're gonna be
talking so good that's because that's
what you guys tuned in for right
perfectly rehearsed podcasts the entire
thing and didn't realize that our audio
was not recording until we were done
then we tried again for like maybe five
minutes in Game Boy I think that I might
have talked about this in the podcast
before but like my biggest pet peeve is
doing the thing that's again especially
if I thought that they were just fine or
great the first time and I thought that
the version 1.0 was really good and but
like do anything that again just makes
me so rage and usually I'm a pretty
happy guy I'm easygoing I I'm very
optimistic and everything but like this
one thing just makes me like raizy not
upset cuz like it makes you upset - and
I think that Europe you're upset you
lose work - yeah I get upset you get
angry angry I'm not that much makes me
angry I think bad drivers and doing
things twice well I will say from from a
perspective outside of yourself you
don't really come off as angry you come
off as upset just like a more extreme
upset well you know internal there's
literally like a fire burning within me
and like I want to go to the gym and
like find a punching bag or something
like that is that intense I don't
actually went to the gym
I want to go on amazon.com one day prime
a punching bag mounted to the ceiling
and then buy that all won't be upset
anymore but I'll be prepared for the
next time I have to do something again
instead we play some minecraft and watch
some YouTube videos yeah
and now this time version 3.0 it's gonna
be the best it's gonna be smooth smooth
[Music]
smooth - say how do we do that voice
effects again we haven't really done
that much oh yeah I can do the voice
[Music]
it's so much fun for us oh my gosh okay
so now that we've rehearsed the three
times we know we're talking about okay
I'm glad you asked we're gonna be
talking about like a new segment where
we talked about what's been going on in
our lives for the past week then we're
gonna go on to a question from one of
our listeners I think from patreon and
then we're gonna go on to the thing of
the week okay so I'll start with Project
egress stuff for those of you who
haven't like seen our post about it or
anything it's via the Smithsonian's
National Air and Space Museum they kind
of reached out to Adam Savage and his
team at tested and Savage industries and
they kind of put together this idea of
recreating the escape hatch from the
Apollo 11 landing module and it's going
to be a Frankenstein of like all sorts
of different makers coming together to
make this project reality yeah so Adams
team reached out to like 50 I think
different makers slash makerspaces slash
teams to each do an individual part so
we did one of those parts yeah but a lot
of different like YouTube makers did
that we that were friends with as well
yeah I mean like you know Jimmy drops
Joel from 3d printing nerd
yeah like Stephanie I mean there's like
tons we'll link to where tested has all
of the people listed out and stuff but
it's great because like there's such a
wide variety of parts I mean the
saunders machine shop they're like they
have a channel called NYC and c and if
you guys have looked up like c and c
videos like a normal person like i have
i mean they'd like took the engineer
drawings and like legit made them out of
like aluminum and steel and they like
colored it and they did all different
materials they anodized things some
people made pieces out of wood yeah
someone did ceramics i'm not sure who we
just heard that someone did like a
ceramic piece and i think it's like a
joint between two other pieces but the
hatch that we're recreating it's not
like a functional it's not it's more of
an art piece this is a treat together
but they don't have to tribute to the
Apollo 11 mission which you know we're
you know the u.s. went to the moon which
is really really cool I mean think about
50 years ago my but either of our phones
has more computing power than the entire
like the than any computer back then
like they went up into space and back
with less computing power than our cell
phones and the computers they use to
calculate things back then with like the
I don't know if it was like hand punch
calculators stick things I mean there's
a lot of hand calculations and stuff and
our phones our phones are more powerful
than any computer back then and we
figured out how to do that and it's just
insane and there's this documentary
called Apollo 11 we'll have a link to
that down below too and it this seems
really cool I kind of found it in
connection to this project egress that
we were that we have going on and it's
really cool and I want to watch it
because it's a documentary but there's
no voiceover this is the thing that
makes a difference all of the talking is
from TV commentary and
the discussions that they went through
the archive so there is no like narrator
saying like back you know like like on
April 12th this happened and then this
happened etcetera etcetera it's like no
all like TV commentary and discussions
that were in the moment while it was all
happening these repurpose the footage
into a different type of format into a
format and kind of made like a little
bit of a more movie like feel to it like
they're transporting you there and stuff
and they found all this unreleased never
seen before footage and stuff that makes
me think of Alex deal yeah because he I
think it's like UK History Channel or
something like that had had or still has
a show where they take his footage from
his YouTube channel and format it down
for TV show episodes so they like take
his multi-part sword builds and make it
one episode but it was crazy because
when we were doing our collab with him
he had gotten like a preview file of one
of it generic Merida with a British
accent he did I can't do his footage but
to piece it all together they had some
narrated pieces and so we're listening
and then all of a sudden we hear this
voice going hello I'm Alex steel
[Laughter]
actually did like Alec did the
voice-over and basically for the real
one for those of you who haven't seen
Alex Steel's channel he he's an amazing
blacksmith and he makes crazy weapons
but on YouTube his each episode is
probably like 10 20 minutes and
sometimes there's 12 parts for like 20
or 20 parts or 30 parts for a single
sword or something like that post almost
every day yeah so what this channel did
and what this content creation or what
this like studio did is they took all
that raw footage they recut it and added
a voiceover and they turned like one 30
or 40 minute episode out of like all
that content and sometimes they pulled
content from like three of his series to
make a single episode online so that all
this raw footage
and then they did the voice-over and
everything interesting I wonder if that
will happen more in the future where TV
companies will find like a like a proven
success on YouTube and say like oh I
think that can make good content the
crazy thing is some companies are doing
that right now like bone Appetit
they are repurposing their content and
they're putting it on like Roku and
Apple TV and like all these other things
like series yeah they're not like
cutting three of Brad's videos together
and re editing it to make it something
different so if they recut just a few of
our videos together to make TV show what
would it be the resin files the resin
files it's just us running around
screaming all the time like panicking
that's caring it's a montage of me
saying like I don't like this I'm gonna
add a little bit more oh no I made it
worse
it seems to be a trend it seems to be
yeah I think one reason why we want to
do this whole like what's new with us in
the past week is some things that we do
just don't make it into any of our
content and we still want to talk about
and still want to share with you and I
think that this just makes the most
sense like to share it in podcast form
like I think if we didn't tell people
that oh we're starting a new section of
our podcast where we're just gonna talk
about what's new I think people wouldn't
even notice but his most podcast start
with a like what's new yeah what are you
working on what's new with you but I
think in the past we've just like yeah
we've just started the podcast we've
jumped straight into a topic and then we
play a game and then you wrap up
sometimes we do story times but like all
the story times we've done have been
like vacation stories or childhood
stories or what have you you know yes
now we're going to project egress yeah
project egress so so when they reached
out to us we were making this part it's
like a linkage between two hinges and in
the actual hatch it like
moves two levers in parallel and when I
looked at the file I wanted to make it
adjustable so I added real threads I
like modeled in threads into the file it
was just like solid it was pretty fancy
I doesn't need padding my back I tried
to like make it loud so that people
listening to just audio would hear it
I'll miss the treat of you like hunching
over towards the mic patting your butt
back is that all the people watching the
video will get Oh YouTube Watchers
you're welcome
so I modeled in the threads so that's
fancy and adjustable and I also wanted
us to like stand out and be a little bit
fancy and I went with laser 3d printing
because there's these swivel points in
the 3d model that like actually function
in real life you know because the whole
thing swivels and hinges and stuff so my
thought was to model everything in and
print super super accurately because we
have lasers but what I didn't check is
the recommended gap between two walls so
that things don't fuse together and by
that point we were kind of running out
of time because you know we accepted
this project but we also have
commitments to lots of other sponsors
when we accepted it we decided to not
make a video about it one because like
we were weren't really sure how
satisfying of a video it would be
because it's just us doing one part of a
much bigger piece but also doing a video
makes it take at least twice we didn't
have much time so it was a smart idea
looking backwards totally we shipped
that out like the week it was due not
much spare time but since we weren't
making a video on it we still had to
make our normal normally scheduled
videos so we're still making it and
filming videos at the same time so it's
yeah all plus I'm in the past two weeks
have been crazy with the old spice maybe
we should talk about the old spice
sometime that could maybe be a whole
topic old spice we just
so that launched according to you guys
and when this is being released that
launched like three days ago it's Friday
today so we literally just watched
boy that was an adventure yes it was a
good adventure
I mean Old Spice and and the agencies we
worked with they were all on the same
page everyone was trying to make this
happen
but because it was such a big company
there were five companies involved all
five companies yeah so lots of people
lots of approval and like I understand
because Old Spice has like a brand they
want to make sure that everything is
like on their marketing points and
within like the guidelines and
everything but but I think we're so used
to like it's us and the person making
the decision those are the two people
communicating it's like content creation
speed is like quick you know most the
time we're working on our video for the
current week or if we're lucky the next
week and that's as far of a lead as we
ever have you know so it's always like
things are happening quickly but because
like we need to send it to one person
that person sends it to another person
that person sends it to another person
who has to submit the result to a
supervising company to make sure that
fits in with it though because one
company's owned by another company and
everything and it's just like like it
takes like a week for the feedback loop
at times you know what I mean and like
to get everything like the ball rolling
so it was just like it was just business
add another scale that we weren't fully
used to everyone you know we were all
like working together to try to make it
happen by this morning everyone was on
the same page everyone was on the same
team but it's just funny because it was
like so down to the wire like oh my gosh
we we were really close we almost always
launched at 11:00 a.m. on Fridays CST
and we launched it I think 12:30 cuz
like we were still waiting on like the
final contracts like we hadn't even
signed the contract right before yeah so
on on Tuesday before the video launch in
the video that launched its Old Spice
but that's the sponsor not the video
it's the live ocean ocean light
yes that's it and so we basically
finished the project and edit Tuesday
before launch and we submitted it at
like 1:00 and then at that point we had
no clue whether it was going to be
launched that week or not and we were
like oh man if if it's not approved are
we gonna have to come up with a new
video for the drink I'm just gonna take
a buffer week like what are we gonna do
and then on Wednesday we still had no
clue Thursday we got the word that it
was going to be approved but it wasn't
approved on Thursday and it was like oh
it's gonna be Thursday and of day but
then more delays were hit and it was
Friday right literally right before we
launched it was approved Friday at 11:00
and then we got the contract Friday noon
and then we published and then we ate
and we like we're able to relax for the
first time in a while proved and I mean
not normally in a scenario like this we
would schedule this really really far
out but because of fiscal years and
budgeting and everything it had to be
rushed from there and too so it was just
a little bit of a learning that the
angle but also I mean I think a lot of
content creators especially in LA they
might run on a faster schedule because
they can film faster and they can edit
faster and depends on the scope I don't
think people in LA can film faster oh
let's say that you're filming a skit or
something or if the entire thing was a
skit so we did a skit and then we did a
multi-day build with resin curing and
there's no ability to rush resin curing
a lot of the examples they send us from
people they had worked with before the
whole video was just the skit yes so but
because we're not a skit channel we did
the skit as the ad spot but then we had
to do a whole video video afterwards you
know
and like like one of the agencies is in
LA that had the product and we had to
kind of run around to five stores to
find the right products with the new
updated there's a lot of shenanigans
there's a lot of sand against it was
definitely like I'm so glad we did it it
was a huge learning experience really
great it was interesting because it was
like the biggest company with the most
like in-betweens that we've ever done
yeah but also this it's really cool
because I think we've talked about in
the podcast before we love all of our
sponsors but we've always kind of
wondered why some of the like the in air
quotes bigger companies that spend a lot
of money on TV we've been wondering like
when some of those larger companies that
have the huge budgets when are they
gonna go into like YouTube and I think
that we're talking on our monthly
patreon hangouts with some of our
patrons there and a lot of them are in
marketing it turns out and a few of them
have experience at these big companies
and one of the things we learned from
our patrons was these big companies they
have such a huge budget that if they
spread it out across a thousand content
creators it'd be such a big campaign to
manage and it's a lot easier to make one
thing and put all their money behind
that one thing and just blasted across
TV as opposed to with a whole bunch of
individual tailored campaigns basically
content creators are too cheap it's it's
well but it's like it's also I think
they're like they can say let's put this
in front of 100 200 500 million people
you know really ease it with a push of a
button it's gonna cost a lot of money
and they may not be paying attention and
they may DVR through it but supposedly
it's gonna reach these like billion
people you know we're with YouTube if
you want to reach a billion people you
need to put it on like hundreds of
videos if you if you're if you reach out
to ten people or a hundred a hundred
people that all get a million and you
had to vet every channel and you have to
make sure that I
your your branding fits with that
channels content and you know it's like
because all content kind of needs to be
tailored to some degree for the channel
like if we're gonna give like an
endorsement if we're gonna like do a
little a spot on our channel first we
need to get the product make sure it
like we like it which thankfully we did
and then we need to like figure out a
strategy with a company so that like our
messaging and our brand fits with theirs
and we have to merged them and it's just
with hundreds of channels hundreds or
thousands times over yeah and that's why
there's so many agencies and that's why
I like the load gets distributed like
the the guidance comes from up here then
it splits into agencies and those
agencies have leads and those leaves
reach out to people and they're all like
yeah goes back and forth it's a big
to-do but I think that it is a lot more
effective because you do get those
personalized messages yeah so
interesting yeah yeah well and part of
that too is like with big companies if
you have a budget and you don't spend it
all next year you get a smaller budget
yeah that's how I like most corporations
work so it couldn't just be like oh well
we'll just only spend half of it this
year and just work with 50 content
creators just to test it out it's like
no you got to spend at all yeah oh you
didn't need this oh there's extra budget
okay will absorb it over into whatever
you know yeah that's crazy
it's so interesting yeah oh wow so that
was kind of a long side tangent hey
version 3 the best version you guys are
getting the best version because we
didn't even talk about that in version
one or two virgin another thing that has
been going on lately is our hunt for the
new camera cameras actually we just
bought it and I'm imagining like the
music the hunt the hunt music again and
it's like the one that was playing at
the beginning of one of the things to
get into getting it thinking that's all
you're singing right
we used in the old face video when
you're hunting for products I know the
song but you can't sing your song so
accurately just replace all of our music
with your song you know how like there's
obviously a lot of songs you can't use
on YouTube for copyright reasons oh yeah
we should just sing them we should just
sing them I can show you my resume we
should just start our next channel our
fifth channel evident Caitlyn musings
evident Kalyan Singh this the grammar is
just as good as all other four channels
three healthy ones and one dead one is
all we can handle right now dead it's
just dormant
cuz we don't know what to do with
evident Caitlyn - you know what it will
happen something will happen or we'll
change the name and make it something
else yes true subscribe therefore camera
camera hunt yeah so this has been a
long-term project of mine and I think
that I've been on it off and on for
probably two years mm-hmm like since we
started the channel really because when
we started the channel we had a Fuji XT
10 that I had gotten for free from like
a work event and so we're just like oh
we'll just use that because we have it
yeah and it you know what it's pretty I
like the color science of it I like the
colors it's got the nice blurry
background there's a lot of good things
going for it
but there there are a few things that
are abso lutely
in fear ting ting do you like one
one-hundredth of how frustrated we were
on like a daily basis using this camera
like it was fine if you were if you had
it on a tripod and the thing you were
filming was not changing its distance
from the camera yeah so like that like
the things that are like I'm gonna go
through the list of things that I
absolutely hated about that camera one
the autofocus was really really slow it
was slow and inaccurate there's so many
clips of us where it's just us like
yelling at the camera like focus so it
could not focus it was horrible you slow
it focused focusing there is like some
firmware issue with our main lens that
had like the kit lens that came with it
that could zoom and had some optical
image stabilization so that's what we
use when we're hand-holding it when we
set it down on a tripod it freaked out
you couldn't turn off optical image
stabilization even if you like flick the
lever on the lens just like and so every
time we switched from handheld to tripod
we had to also change the lens because
we could use our like our about fixed
lenses or fixed zoom lenses on the
tripod and then the zoom lens handheld
yeah in the prime we're kind of prettier
because like we had got a prime pancake
lens that went down to F 1.4 so that was
like the most super blurry thing they
said it makes everything look artistic
because you focus on one thing and
everything in the background is blurry
and there's like a separation that
happens and if you have a messy
background no worries that's how we hit
our mouse for like years so so we had
that one was on the tripod but then we
had to switch lenses in the middle of
like filming and that there's a lot of
bad things about that often after
woodworking or our
hands are messy yes like imagine Rison
you know resin hands and we're swapping
lenses that's not good
and it also like interrupts our flow
because like we suck at acting we are
not good in our commercial okay maybe
we're getting better at skits but that's
like a very specific type of acting it's
not really like being genuine you know
it's like you can be exaggerated in a
little bit extra because we can do that
but uh oh yeah yeah so it's like
interrupting our flow if we have an idea
we want to capture it right then it's
hard to like hold on to idea and then
deliver that line because you have to
like swap lenses cuz like it's on a
tripod then you want to flip it up and
you have that switch
anyways yeah so so the next camera I
don't know what there's another thing
that I hated okay another thing is the
menu system switching iso's yet it let
go it was bad it was slow we got a
second camera late last year the Canon
150 Oh put a link to it Canada in 50
great little super super super easy to
use camera pretty cheap no it downside
is it doesn't it didn't look the
prettiest and that's what most of our
recent videos have been filmed on
primarily any time we're hand-holding it
it's it's that camera and so it's fine
but you don't get like the blurry you
know I'm still recommend I still really
like love it I love it and I would
recommend it as anyone's first Youtube
camera it's like it is a perfect YouTube
camera and then everything you need I
buy that one thing and you're good to
get going right away with like you know
it has stabilization that has the flip
out screen and it has a good menu system
it has good video workflow everything
about it is really really good it's just
and we're probably still gonna use it
for a lot of stuff it's just like it
doesn't get like that super pretty feel
that some cameras have yeah you don't
get the blurry background and
it there's a little bit less like range
of darks to lights so sometimes the
darks get a little too dark so move the
lights get a little too light so do you
want to say what the new camera is that
we have the new camera is the eos same
interface as our usm 50 which i love
don't have to learn a new one because i
hate learning new camera interfaces and
we got like a kit lens with it that's a
24 to 105 lens and it has a f/4 constant
that means you can zoom through the
whole focal range and keep that for
f-stop and the lower number f-stop you
have which is a bigger opening it's
letting in more light so you get more
blurry background whether you're zoomed
in or zoomed out it still can maintain
that same desktop and it's a full-frame
camera which comes with like a lot of
things going for it makes everything
look a nicer it makes everything look
nice I'm Jenna like because I still I
mean I know camera terms yeah some of
them but I'm trying does not make this
too like techie sorry I won't go into
all these like I haven't so deep into it
and like I think I've been on the hunt
for like that in air quotes perfect
camera for so long I've put in like 30
plus hours I think hopefully it's gonna
be the perfect camera I would say my
only concern is it's about twice the
weight of the m50 the body isn't the
body is just photos we're not gonna be
carrying it around without a lens
yeah the lens is like really heavy it's
pretty happy but that's because it's a
fancier left I understand that and I
know a glass can home you know it's
gonna weigh what its gonna waste gonna
weigh was gonna weigh get the fancy or
look that way you want and we need more
glass in that lens but I'm just gonna
look at it as like my workout program it
is like do do do hammer curls like while
you're filming and then the audience can
do the workout with you they can go up
and down up and down
but yeah but I am I am excited I'm
telling myself that it that the wait
will be a good thing I said I will make
my arms stronger also if it's the weight
is heavier it won't move around as much
because it has more momentum going for
it so it's more momentum means more like
inertia but yeah as you move and stop it
won't like blow away in the wind we have
a podcast episode on this a story time
where we went on those like crazy Alpine
crossing in New Zealand but our camera
case blew away
yeah like ripped off of the camera down
into a volcano and in New Zealand
there's no safety walls there's no fence
you're just on top of the dormant
volcano and there's blue in there and
like like I'm not gonna say it was like
a steep drop-off 5 feet to my right but
it was it was pretty steep and it was
about 5 feet away
we couldn't have oh no no the wind and
like within a second like there's
absolutely no way I could have caught it
or taste it or anything it was just like
yeah yeah and we are at the peak pretty
much at that point yeah tongariro story
yeah but like oh and also we got a
camcorder to go on with this cuz so when
we were doing the Old Spice video we had
the top down we were like man and we
were using our and 50 for the top down
but and then the disc camera that we use
here for the like wider constant shot
and we were like man it'd be so nice to
have two camcorders for these two types
of shots because camcorders record for a
really really long time whereas cameras
will stop recording at 30 minutes and so
well then we were looking it up recently
and it's completely arbitrary the the 30
minute recording limit on cameras it's
all because of a law in the EU that was
enacted back in 2006 like classifying
high-end digital cameras as video
recorders which has attacks but that so
then they like did some shenanigans and
stuff it's just
understand like so it's so nice it's to
keep camcorders on the market to give
them like an advantage that cameras
don't have I think so that's my rough
and understanding if anyone knows more
about this to the law put it in the
comments it's like the camera companies
make the camcorders and the cameras and
the cameras so it's so they can sell to
products instead of wine would be so
much more efficient and you like for
them like price-wise well you can hack
your cameras with this like magical an
turn which is like I'm guessing some of
the comments are gonna be about that but
you can't hack your cameras with this
software upgrade but uh it might void
the warranty and some expensive camera
yeah anyways we got like a mid-range
camcorder as well but the cameras for
the important thing about this this
Canon camcorder that matches the Canon
new camera that we got is now all of our
cameras out there the m50 the eos R and
the camcorder is I believe the Vixia G
50 since they're all canon they're all
using like the same like color science
we can put them on the same profile the
same white balance and it's gonna be so
nice everything should look the same
when you import all of the clips in the
premiere all three cameras will look
basically like they're from one just a
different settings which will be nice
cuz I normally have to color correct
each camera individually yeah which is
it's just a big pain and that best
saving time and like if you think about
like that time that you have to put in
the color correction every single video
and that what that time is worth and how
much that could add up a justifying
money over like hundreds of videos you
know I'm justifying it yes basically
we're making money by buying these games
yes completely we're making money I'm so
glad you see
but also it's like you know it's been
kind of haunting me this decision I felt
a lot of pressure to like figure it out
because we keep on making videos and
they could be made prettier and I know
that's not really the point of our
videos to be like pretty have we had
this conversation when we had it with
patreon maybe with each other okay
everything we had it with our monthly
patreon hangout - okay okay I'm trying
to like remember like what we said like
what was in version one what wasn't -
what was in the chat well I think the
point of what you're saying is like the
the purpose of our videos isn't to have
like the most beautiful shots we're not
like a channel vlog no or something
channel vlog like a Travel Channel vlog
Channel travel that's not like the point
of our videos but we do like we would
like them to look nicer and maybe it's
we're spoiled because like sometimes
we'll look at an old video where we were
using the infuriatingly frustrating but
very pretty Fuji camera yeah and we're
like man
now they're very pretty I think that's
so much of we do has the potential to be
so pretty like the resin things the
woodworking thing there's the finishing
thing that's like we make some pretty
things and I'm like we're never gonna go
back and photograph or video that we're
putting so many hours of work into the
things I just like and like I love
cameras I love videos I love photography
and videography and like I think because
it's one of my in air-quote things if
you listened to our last episode I do
consider that one of my thing this I
think that it bothers me that like I
know I could be doing the exact same
thing and it could look so much better
yeah and it's bothering me that it isn't
because I haven't put in the time and
money into making that decision but now
we have but now we have so next video
will be with the new Vance Cameron oh
yeah might be soap it might be so making
we've been watching a lot of soaps we've
been making way we'll talk about that
later moving on from
yeah I really think we might not get to
the question this time we'll just keep
going with updates I want to talk about
4th of July because if we wait a week
it's gonna be super irrelevant it's
already a little bit irrelevant but well
we haven't our last podcast we recorded
before 4th of July so Evan had his first
4th of July with my family and I've been
excited about it for so long because as
you guys know I love fiery things and so
does my family so 4th of July at our
house is always in like New Year's to
anything any excuse for fireworks has
always been like a really big thing ever
since I was very little like 2025 years
ago we've been like we we do fourth of
July big and so the tradition is my
brother and my dad go pick out fireworks
and they spend only $39 mm-hmm because
the first time they did it my mom asked
how much money is you guys been and
they're like $39 with like a trunk full
of fireworks like mortars all the good
stuff all the fancy stuff the stuff that
you look in your I wish I could just buy
that like when I was younger and stuff I
was like yeah so every year it's it's
just $39
exactly exactly well no he went over by
27 tents this year I think it was a
splurge because you were visiting yeah
yeah
yeah I was super fun like the reason you
hadn't been to one before is cuz you
know when I was younger
oftentimes we were like either just
outside the city limits
our house was or we would go to my
grandparents house and they live outside
the city limits and so we'd always do it
big but then once we started dating like
my family was in California for a while
I don't want to do in California than
the know at their last couple houses
basically yeah
and so you haven't been a part of it
yeah it was really fun it was really fun
I enjoyed myself so much like that was
the first time I had set off the mortars
mm-hm and those were those are like
legit fireworks you set them off and
you're like yeah that's a firework like
like the ones you see it shows the one
do you see it shows I mean they're like
probably slightly smaller down to the
ground but like since they're smaller
down to the ground
they look just as big as the ones that
are higher in there and bigger and
bigger they look just as nice as any
firework you'd see and the motors are
the ones where it's like there's like a
tube and you drop up like a little ball
or a cylinder down into the tube in it
I saw the roman candle for my first time
was exciting funny because you were
holding it backwards I was holding it
backwards
except for my brother's friend who was
like safely standing farther away hey
cuz he was like I don't know about these
fireworks oh I was kind of trusting like
the group so you like make sure I was
doing that right your fault it was me
and my brother and my dad it was our
fault but I wonder your dad Linnet I
wonder if he was like he might have done
that he might have but yeah so my
brother's friend was like um Evan you
might want to turn that around backwards
us yeah yeah my dad might have done that
on purpose Marcus was trolling people
because so so when we do it it's it's
not just one person setting off the
fireworks like this time it was three
everyone's just doing it he's my brother
and my dad all just like doing your own
thing setting off fireworks oh you never
knew when one was gonna start I loved it
because I'm like two might blow up with
the exact same yawns like oh yeah but my
dad was also as you guys were doing
yours he had like some em 50s in his
fifties like a little firecracker no
yeah yeah well individual ones in his
pocket and I would see him pull one out
of his pocket lighter towards you guys
another controlling moment is so there's
the one of those little tiny
firecrackers and black hats black hats
like those are the ones where there's
like usually a string of like 50 and
they're about like a foot long and
they're all in a row and you light them
and you throw them it goes you know no
big deal we had an eight thousand eight
thousand it was like like four times the
size my face is very large this is a
giant roll so it's like I thought they
were gonna like you know distribute it
or cut it or like do something with it
no like they put the entire roll on the
ground and they lit the end and it just
started going up like this isn't fast
enough so it had stopped at one point
like the fuse disconnected or something
I'm not sure why it stopped and they're
like well this isn't fast enough
anyway so they throw it in the fire pit
it was amazing it was like the craziest
it kind of is going down the path you
know it set off a few at a time but
generally it's like kind of in order
down the path of the role but in the
fire pit it was all all at once pretty
much but a lasted a long time last was
just like going thankfully there's also
strong breeze in one direction so like
and there's pretty constant so all the
smoke was going in one direction so we
didn't have to deal with that so that
was a nice Pleasant bonus because
otherwise that could have been like oh
my gosh like so was kind of chaos
speaking of chaos so we did that like
5,000 roll 8,000 roll Hey 8,000 sold the
size of your hole but there's like
another small role that no one was aware
of like Caitlyn's brother had it stashed
away or something so um there's a fire
pit that was like this within this like
like hedge circle was like only one exit
so um the first time like you're I think
your dad threw it in and everyone saw it
everyone was aware of it no one was near
the fire no one was near the fire pit
and they went off and those crazies but
then everyone went back to the fire pit
mm-hmm and my brother was like hey what
if I just throw this in and so he kind
of like goes into the fire pit area
where the chairs are with like within
the hedge and he throws it in the other
family members who were at the fire pit
like it starts going off and I yeah you
know they're getting popped in the
autumn he got him he got really pretty
good I'm really good but they they were
near the entrance of the like hedged
area so they ran out my brother is
trapped because he was on the back end
and he couldn't go past the fire he's
trapped between fireworks in the head
ended up drawing himself he said it he
seemed to still think goes worth it yeah
let's find that was epic
I did at the end like I really liked
setting off multiple at once it's like
David to him and stuff like that but we
only have the lighters and everything
and maybe start thinking that it'd be
really fun to like buy or design or like
come up with some sort of system to
light multiple all at once and I know
that they make those like starter kits
for rockets but I wonder if there's a
way to jig up one of those so I could
start off like five or twenty mortars
all at once can you imagine like twenty
mortars going off in your backyard or
like right above you that would be crazy
that'd be amazing have you the finale
yeah Widow I might have like build some
like like grid of like metal pipes and
like a system for that weld them
together yes yeah we weld in projects
DIY firework yeah we attempt
[Laughter]
yeah pretty fun we can even have like
different diameters for different size
like mortars and stuff I see this like
look of hesitation in your eye and just
like your flamethrowers around the house
are already like dangerous enough by
your hair I haven't gotten you ever and
I never will I like how you said ever
instead of yet thank you
I thought about that and I hesitated
that changed incredibly safe and
thoughtful within my use of fire related
peripherals always also another fun
thing while we're at your parents house
we finally picked up your childhood m64
from like way back in the day we're
gonna play some in 64 games on the
gaming channel on the stream I wonder if
we should modify your n64 like repaint
it do colour changing paint out of it
like we buy a clear case online because
you can buy a clear case embed LEDs in
it so take up out your old one embed
LEDs in it and then reassemble it and if
something goes wrong nevermind maybe
we'll buy like a used one on Amazon and
reassemble them out in there right well
why would we do that we already have a
work that's fine
nevermind okay oh but we're so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna play those
n64 games on Evan and Caitlin gaming and
it's gonna be really excited like
revisit these old classics like Isaac's
for me see if they hold up well some of
them are super classics for me I'm so
excited to play pokemon snap okie
monster oh and those apples at that
Pikachu to jump in that surfboard I see
if we can find Moo it's gonna be great I
think it'll be such a fun game to stream
to because it's just like it'll be fun
I'm not sure if it'll make for good
highlights but we'll just like leave all
that pressure on our editors Thank You
editors
yeah it'll be fun yeah we're also on the
hunt for more editors but for the gaming
channel oh man that's been yeah we've to
right now Burke and Samuel they're both
super awesome super awesome we've worked
with them enough that they know what we
want they know our humor they know our
video or like our the music we use and
everything works super smoothly but
we've started streaming a lot more than
we did when we first brought them on and
so like the backlog is building up and
so we're like oh man maybe we need to
third
we've been looking but it's it's it's
tough to find to find people focus like
we're not looking for just a skilled
editor we're looking for someone with
the same sense of humor for us it's hard
to say like be funny in the way that we
want you to be funny there's almost like
even like have a good sense of humor or
anything it's like I want you to
understand our humor and do the same
thing yeah which is like you can't like
you you have to either have that sense
of humor or not have it but you can't
like fake it and like not many people
have opportunity like if you're an
editor sometimes you might do
professional work or you might have done
like vlogs for someone or who knows but
like maybe you haven't had the chance to
like express your sense of humor in the
way that you want to and it's just like
there are that many people who can like
submit a video that proves that they are
the perfect candidate yeah I'm gonna
play I'm gonna play the song if you like
that's gonna be the outro music
so everyone can hear that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow well we're like 51 minutes in we
ended up talking way longer than we did
the first one this was a better one this
was the better one but we might have to
save our question about what our
families and friends think about our
youtubing for another episode yeah we're
already almost now sorry for like the
false advertising there gosh if you just
have more podcasts good thing we have
all these topics good thing good thing
look at this honestly guys like I'm so
happy we started doing this what's new
segments because there's a lot of things
that like that happened that you know
we've been like oh well we can't really
make that into a full topic so we just
won't cover it
yeah so I think it'll be good to like
have some have like a little what's new
that sometimes might take up an entire
episode sometimes that might just be
like a little section of them all get
into a topic yeah you know we're still
figuring out with us and you'll you'll
the experience you'll experience formats
yet unknown where's our hard coming soon
t-shirt available right now well link it
below
yeah where's a hard t-shirt guys I was
finally out yeah we have it we haven't
announced it yet we were going to in the
next video yeah yeah but we have a words
are hard t-shirts so for those of you
listening and watching you can get it
you can get it first and you can beat
everyone aside from our $20 patrons who
heard about it last night or two nights
ago in our chat yeah so they get it
first because they heard you guys get a
second so since you guys got to hear
about this exclusive podcast exclusive
now for the low price of sharing it with
your friends the podcast yeah okay I
don't wanna yell words are hard again
yes we would we would appreciate a share
of this podcast with your friends or
frenemies or just like internet
strangers and also we really do
appreciate like reading your reviews
it's nice to hear that like these
podcasts that we do just like us sitting
here chatting and catching up or talking
about topics like mean something because
it's fun for us to do to to people we
like
fun but like it's it's like probably our
smallest audience which doesn't really
mean anything as long as it's providing
value to someone it's worth our time
yeah you know I mean okay guys it's time
for the thing of the week
okay so my thing the week is the canon
eos r and the Vixia g50 how I could talk
about can cameras for so long I could
talk about the features I could talk
about why I chose them but that might
not be the most interesting we've
already talked we've kind of already
talked about it okay but those are my
things leak I'm obsessed with them I got
them and like I spent the next hour like
figuring them out like adjusting all the
dials I figure out the setting this is
like midnight it was like our you know
new technology I am figuring them out
I'm setting it all up like okay look at
this dial this dial does this you can
push this button and it does this that's
like I just get excited about it yeah
yeah quite I mean I don't want to say
not as excited as you it's for me the
like figuring out of the buttons I'm
just like okay I just need to know what
I need to know to do it there's an
excitement in it
yeah I I we didn't go there's another
side but like I did think about the
possibility of starting like evident
take Caitlin tech or something like that
like a tech channel like reviews or tips
tricks whatever but like I realized that
there aren't enough videos even if we
had the time besides the time when we
don't have the time but even if we had
the time magically we don't buy enough
things and there isn't enough
reoccurring content for years and years
of evident Caitlin technology
sustainable or cheap yeah yeah even
though I love things I mean technology
maybe sevens Evans like tech minute on
the podcast yeah yeah Evans tech minute
oh like coming soon guys um pcs ultra
mobile PCs so hopefully something is in
the mail from China for me but something
tiny and something tiny and cute but you
know it's like you ordered these
specialty products sometimes they take a
while sometimes they're not out yet so
as soon soon to come my think so like we
briefly mentioned earlier we've been
looking at soap making videos because we
might want to try making some soaps a
lot of people have requested it and I
was like no I'm interested in learning
mm soaps sounds cool I mean the research
we found it it's kind of like resonance
some ways making things start kicking in
stuff happens this resin to Jason it's
like resin that you can like put on your
body yes unlike resin do not let resin
on your body
unnecessary disclaimers by evan but one
channel we found in we've only watched
like a handful of her videos but they're
super cute it's royalty soaps and she
just makes a bunch of crazy really fun
soaps like the most recent video is like
a beer soap video where it was just
going crazy she's really cute and funny
there's a lot of variety that goes into
soaps I found out there's like hollow
different methods there's like the cold
method the hot method be like melt and
pour method there's so much and then
there's just like so much you can do
like look if you look at her some nails
that they all look like crazy desserts
and food and stuff there's just like
crazy some of them are food well say
yeah there's food and some of the food
based yeah and like dried food what else
get us know and then we watch one with
beer what do you mean knows you could
totally put skin but that's unsanitary I
feel like I saw skills maybe unless they
were like soap skittles they might have
been like soap skittles like you mold
skittles out of soap isn't even bad guys
I'm just going by a quick glance at a
thumbnail
okay there's now the expert I watched a
few YouTube videos I think we already
did our ask at the end so is this the
end thank you guys for listening this
has been super fun hanging out with you
guys and chit-chatting with you guys
we'll see you next time
you know do you buy
[Music]